alors que les ukrainiens célèbre une
journée de l'unité pour la paix décrété
mercredi par le président volodymyr et
lens qui des manoeuvres militaires
ukrainiennes ont été organisées à
travers le pays comme ici près de la
frontière bélarus kiev reste donc en
état d' alerte au lendemain de l'annoncé
du retrait de plusieurs troupes russes
des frontière ukrainienne et les images
fournies par les autorités russes
montrant ses blindés rentrant vers leurs
casernes nourrissent depuis mardi
l'espoir d'une sortie de crise mais les
occidentaux et l'otan ont reçu ces
annonces avec prudence l'alliance
atlantique se dit prête à poursuivre les
discussions
mais attend toujours de vérifier ce
retrait effectif
nous avons pris note des signes
formulées par la russie sur la volonté
de poursuivre les efforts diplomatiques
mais jusqu'à présent nous n'avons fait
aucune des escalades sur le terrain
contraire il semble que la russie
continue son déploiement militaire
côté européen le chef de la diplomatie
salue ce qu'il a qualifié de signe de
détente et bruxelles déplore les
messages contradictoires envoyés par
moscou
la russie a envoyé des signaux
contradictoires d'une part les autorités
ont annoncé des retraits de troupes
russes et d'autres par le parlement
russe a voté la reconnaissance formelle
des régions de donetsk est lougansk en
tant que républicain indépendant au gpra
blakes le président russe a pour sa part
répété mardi ne pas vouloir d'une guerre
tout en martelant que l'expansion de
l'otan constituer une menace pour son
pays
mardi la maison blanche a fait savoir
que washington souhaite donner toutes
ses chances à la diplomatie mais sans
relâcher la pression face au risque d'
attaque contre l'ukraine notamment au
moyen de sanction économique qualifiée
de massive